depth of field is an important part of
any motion design piece in this tutorial
I'm going to show you how to improve
your depth of field in After Effects
[Music]
hey my name is Cameron with motion
science and in this tutorial I'm going
to show you how to improve your depth of
field inside of After Effects now depth
of field is super important if you want
to direct the viewer's attention or you
want to create a sense of depth in your
work so if you want to take your work up
a notch let me show you how it's done
okay so here we are inside of After
Effects and I've got a animation
happening on screen here first off we're
going to make this a lot more
interesting by adding a camera so I have
camera one which we see right here and
what I'm going to do is just turn this
camera on and you're going to see I've
set some options up here inside of
transform so that we have position
already set we've got a wiggle Express
which I've turned off and we have
orientation sets X rotation zero y
rotation set to 25 but if I turn this on
immediately you're going to see how much
more interesting this is right just by
adding a 3D camera inside of after
effects on 99 of all my projects I work
on I use a 3D camera and and that is for
various reasons but one of the reasons
is so I can get interesting angles like
we see here but what we can do is make
this even more interesting by playing
around with the camera options which are
found here and in today's tutorial we're
going to play around with zoom depth of
field Focus distance aperture blur level
and Irish shape the options below Irish
rotation through highlight saturation
these are ones you can play around with
I find that I use these very very little
like one percent of the time the
majority of the time using these
settings right here you're going to get
a lot more interesting looks so how can
we make this more interesting let's
start with our Zoom which we see right
here so let's go ahead and crank up our
zoom and by doing that we're actually
going to kind of push in on this shot
here and I found that a value of around
4266
is looking pretty good so I'm nice and
tight on this image here that is zoom
next we have depth of field let's go
ahead and turn it on and by default most
of the time you're not going to see a
whole lot of things change it looks
pretty much the same so that's on and
this is off what we can do to make this
look more interesting is to crank up the
aperture so depending on your camera
preset your aperture value here is going
to be different but I like to crank this
value way up there so maybe if we crank
it up to something like 347 you're going
to see all of a sudden we're getting
focus distance happening here so for
this project I actually cranked this
value way up there and this is higher
than I do for a lot of projects but for
this one looks pretty interesting I'm
going to put in 2500 and you can see oh
it's just a blurred jumbled mess to look
at but what we can do is start playing
around with our Focus distance which we
can crank up or down here so I can crank
this down and you're going to see things
are going to start to come into focus by
pulling this down down down we're seeing
some things come into Focus here so what
I can do is I can actually jump down
here into two views now in this top view
here I can see where my camera is
focusing and I can see that by looking
at this line here so if I drag the focus
distance you're going to see as I drag
to the right it's getting further away
as I drag to the left it's getting
closer so this is how I can kind of
adjust my focus where I want it to be
I'm going to go ahead and pull it down
to something like this and as you can
see here on the right side I'm zoomed in
on this Boston 34 so let's go back to
one View and kind of zoom in here and
we're on Boston
34. so what I'm going to do now is move
up in my timeline we're gonna go to
about 1 12 or so and we're going to set
a keyframe here for Focus distance and
we're going to go one second down so
let's go to 212 and let's just play
around with our Focus here and let's
pull the focus even tighter so we're
focused in on this second area here
something like that and then let's move
a little bit further down and we'll set
a second keyframe and say hey we're
still here and we'll go one more second
so
504 and then we're going to pull those
down even more so we can focus in on
this area here and let's find a good
value for this somewhere right in here
yeah it's nice and in Focus here because
what I have is some type that's coming
on here at this point now so now if I
select all these and I right click and
say keyframe easy ease and I preview
this we have a pretty cool look already
and in our preview you can see how much
more interesting this is right so we're
focused on Boston 34 and then the
password and then login so we're really
focusing the viewers attention on what
it is that we're typing in on this login
screen and it just creates a lot more
visual interest for our viewer by using
this depth of field settings here so
let's just look really quickly here at a
couple more settings blur level is set
to 100 typically I leave this at 100 but
if you want to create even more blur
than what we have here you can go to
something like 200 percent and this is
just going to create even more blur
right it looks a little crazy there
another way you could do this is just
crank down the aperture let's say from
2500 to a thousand right and these
values are really really high but I
wanted a high blur value and then we
could take the blur level up to 200
percent and we we get a very similar
look like this so if I take a screenshot
here
that's blur level 200 we'll go back to
100 percent and we'll take this to 25.
100 pixels and we'll compare and you see
here we pretty much get the same basic
look so that's another way you could uh
approach this and then lastly we have
Iris shape Now by default After Effects
defaults to fast rectangle this is
because this renders a lot faster I
typically always work in preview mode
whenever I'm I'm designing something and
getting it kind of just right I'm going
to leave it at fast rectangle once I'm
ready to go to a final render I like to
use hexagon or heptagon personally but
let me show you what this looks like so
we have a screen capture here of the the
current render fast rectangle and we're
going to switch it over here to Triangle
you're going to see the look of this
change as it switches over but you can
also see how much longer it's taking to
render just one single frame
and there it is and this is fast
rectangle versus triangle right and you
can see like look right here at the
corner there's a triangle right here
also here on this corner we're seeing a
triangle so again fast rectangle not the
prettiest depth of field blur but it
works right it's very quick here's
triangle let's also take a look at
Square
so you're going to see things change
like from this triangle here is going to
have probably four sides to it right so
it's a little bit smoother blur there
let's go to Pentagon again Pentagon
meaning five so we're going to have even
more geometry to work with looks even
better personal favorite of mine is
hexagon and then this is the one
heptagon that I tend to use the majority
of the time when I'm outputting a final
renderer to me it just looks you know
really nice so there's heptagon and then
here's fast rectangle so you can see it
just has a little bit nicer blur to it
it looks a little bit uh looks nicer to
me and that my friends is how you create
a better depth of field in After Effects
with the camera options I hope that you
really enjoy this lesson as much as I
loved teaching it so please let me know
if you have any questions in the
comments below I'd love to answer them
for you hit that like button if you
enjoyed this video and please subscribe
to this channel it helps other people
find this channel as well if you're
looking to upgrade your design skill set
Master the art of style and execute like
a pro I have a course called stylecraft
that you can check out at
motionscience.tv you can also learn more
about this course by clicking the link
in the description below as always
thanks for watching my name is Cameron
and this is motion science
[Music]